alors j'ai envie de commencer par vous
bertrand martinot code du travail quel
est le problème comment en est on arrivé
là pourquoi le système ne marche pas on
vous écoute
merci merci beaucoup alors à ce vaste
question évidemment
donc pour revenir faire trois constats
qui sont de plus en plus partagé ce
n'était pas le cas il ya quelques années
mais là qui effectivement comme vous
l'avez rappelé et m'a même le callennec
même à gauche effectivement terra nova
etc on a on a des des convergences de
vues au moins sur quelques éléments de
diagnostic et dont constat alors le
constat il tient aux gros en trois ans
trois choses avec quelque chose de
factuel
c'est que le il ya une explosion du
volume législatif en matière de droit du
travail
on va prendre depuis trente ans on
estime que le nombre de pages du code du
travail en matière législative a été
multiplié par trois donc depuis 1985
alors 1985 je pense ça comme référence
d'abord parce que ça fait juste 30 ans
c'est un chiffre rond mais aussi parce
que 1985 c'est pas la préhistoire du
droit du travail quand même on avait
déjà les lois auroux on avait déjà
évidemment tout le droit syndical on
avait un droit du licenciement qui était
déjà relativement bien constituer donc
et les gens ne se sentaient pas
forcément très mal au travail donc
multiplié par trois depuis depuis 80
depuis 1985 depuis 30 ans ce qui est
quelque chose d'absolument étonnant
alors le deuxième le deuxième constat
c'est que
c'est que le droit n'est pas de plus en
plus protecteur pour le salarié c'est à
dire qu'on pourrait s'attendre le
fondement du droit du travail c'est
d'essayer de rééquilibrer le rapport de
force entre le salarié et l'employeur
qui par nature ne veux pas être un pur à
feurs un peu rapport de droit civil
puisque évidemment il y as derrière un
élément salariale c'est-à-dire un
élément de subsistance pour le salarié
et sa famille
donc le droit est il plus protecteur on
peut on pourrait se dire finalement en
multipliant par trois les textes
législatifs
on pourrait on pourrait s'attendre à ce
que ce qu'ils soient plus protecteur et
alors là on a effectivement une
inefficacité à c'est assez remarquable
du droit du travail de ce point de vue
là puisque il n'a absolument pas
augmenter diminuer la précarité au
travail
alors on va pas dire c'est le droit du
travail qui a créé toute la précarité
dans ce pays évidemment il ya bien
d'autres facteurs économiques et sociaux
qui sont à l'heure mais pour le moins il
n'a pas empêché la précarité et la
montée du chômage
c'est à dire que le droit du travail est
un peu de plus en plus comme une ligne
maginot
c'est à dire que vous essayez de
construire des du béton armé des dalles
de béton armé de trois à quatre mètres
d'épaisseur puis vous rendez compte en
fait que on passe par au dessus on passe
par à côté on passe même par dessous ont
créé des tunnels et c'est donc le droit
est de moins en moins protecteurs dont
précarité montée du chômage
alors la montée du chômage isabelle le
callennec l'a rappelé c'est évidemment
pas uniquement le droit du travail il
faudrait parler évidemment de coût du
travail il faudrait parler de formation
initiale musique et surnaturel préparer
de formation professionnelle d'assurance
chômage
les causes du chômage en france sont
multiples et le droit du travail
évidemment sa part parce que comme vous
l'avez rappelé il y à des emplois qui
sont détruits mais aussi ceux qu'on ne
parle pas c'est qu'ils emploient qui ne
sont pas créés et là dans un certain
nombre de cas le droit du travail est
clairement des incitatifs al embauche
donc le droit plus protecteur non
vis-à-vis en termes de précarité et de
chômage en termes de dialogue social il
ya un effondrement de cris une trentaine
depuis 40 ans on fait maintenant 2 les
adhésions aux syndicats
et donc on peut pas dire que le droit du
travail le droit syndical qui est
extrêmement dense touffu dans notre pays
et contribuer à la mobilisation des
salariés pour plus de dialogue social
troisième constat droit plus protecteur
non le mal être au travail le stress le
burn-out l'explosion des arrêts maladie
on peut pas dire que l'extraordinaire
profusion du droit du travail en matière
de santé de sécurité y compris
d'ailleurs de santé mentale au travail
protège les salariés il ya un mal être
au travail
il ya des relations de défiance dans
l'entreprise quand on regarde les
relations et les rapports internationaux
les comparaisons internationales quand
encore il faut pas tout mettre sur le
dos du droit du travail mais à tout le
moins ils ne contribuent pas à la
solution
enfin troisième constat l'explosion de
la jurisprudence on pourrait s'attendre
à ce que comme il ya beaucoup de loi il
y ait peu de jurisprudence et que le
juge en fait soient tenus et qui est peu
de joueurs espagnols
or le paradoxe français c'est qu'on a le
pire en gros des deux systèmes qui est
la common law britannique et le droit
continental européen c'est à dire qu'on
a beaucoup beaucoup de lois mais on a
aussi beaucoup beaucoup de jurisprudence
je rappelle par exemple qu'en droit du
licenciement le problème n'est pas tant
le code du travail lui-même qui est
relativement court sur ce sujet en
comparaison par exemple avec l'allemagne
en revanche il est de plus en plus
jurisprudentielle et posent de plus en
plus de problèmes
on pourrait dire la même chose du droit
delà de la santé et de la sécurité au
travail qui est de plus en plus
jurisprudentielle alors deux idées
simples pour essayer d'en arrêter avec
cette cette inflation législative qui
sont dues à la fois au gouvernement mais
aussi aux législateurs via des
amendements en nocturne etc
c'est d'abord de revenir une lecture
orthodoxe de la constitution c'est à
dire remettre la loi à sa place remettre
l'état à sa place c'est à dire sans
tenir comme le dit la constitution aux
principes généraux du droit du travail
donc en matière de contrats de travail
de liberté syndicale d'institutions
représentatives du personnel de durée du
travail et même de formation
professionnelle et donc la contrepartie
évidemment c'est que la négociation se
fait essentiellement dans les
entreprises mais aussi dans les branches
professionnelles
car il ne faut pas se faire d'illusion
la négociation en entreprise est très
très faible dans les moins de 50 dans
les moins de 50 dans les entreprises de
moins de 50 salariés il y à 35% donc des
entreprises de ces entreprises qui n'ont
ni délégués syndicaux ni institutions
représentatives du personnel
donc si on va vers une décentralisation
des normes en matière du droit du
travail
la contrepartie c'est que les branches
soit beaucoup plus fort beaucoup plus
armés beaucoup moins nombreuses et là il
ya un énorme travail à faire et ça ne se
fera pas en claquant les doigts
il ya c'est quelque chose d'absolument
fondamentale ensuite deuxième
deuxième piste de solution deuxième idée
simple j'ai dit que l'état devait être
remis à sa place
mais l'état doit aussi occupé toute sa
place c'est à dire ne pas se défausser
sur les partenaires sociaux
interprofessionnelle pour réformer dans
les matières absolument fondamental que
j'ai rappelé et de ce point de vue
malgré les quelques succès initiaux en
on peut dire que globalement l'idée de
remettre la clé aux partenaires sociaux
interprofessionnelle dans qui sont en
fait des collèges différents
c'est à dire on prend un accord national
interprofessionnel et ensuite on le
transcrire dans la loi
force est de constater qu'à part
quelques succès initiaux en 2007 c'est
globalement un échec
on a reconstruit ça a plutôt contribué à
augmenter le volume du droit du travail
on a fait quelques ces dernières années
d'un certain nombre de réformes qui
étaient de véritables usines à gaz en
matière de réforme de la formation
professionnelle en matière une
complication adresse sembla du droit du
travail à temps partiel des accords
compétitivité emploi qui sont
complètement verrouillé et une assurance
chômage qui ne se réforme pas tout ça ce
sont des allusions à des accords
nationaux interprofessionnels des trois
dernières années les partenaires sociaux
interprofessionnelle ont tendance en
fait a répliqué au niveau national les
mêmes travers que l'état c'est à dire ne
rien lâcher ne pas décentraliser la
négociation contrôler et construire des
usines à gaz
donc la solution c'est encore une fois
que l'état se campe sur les principes
fondamentaux
reste à sa place mais encore une fois
occupe sa place et ne pas déléguer les
choses essentielles comme il a été fait
ces dernières années